(upbeat music)
- [Haida] Wow, that is bad!
- [Fenneko] I wouldn't wear that on a bet.
- Who sends this to their
25-year-old daughter?
- Maybe it's in a mom's DNA
to be a pain in the butt.
(heavy-metal music)
- Any men in your life I
should know about dear?
(ding and spit)
Getting married and having a family
is a regular part of growing up.
You know that I'm right, don't you?
You can't just skate through life.
- [Washimi] Huh? She's marrying you off?
- Retsuko, you're getting married?
- [Retsuko] Lay off already!
- I'm gonna work in the
accounting department
starting today! My name's Anai!
- Work ain't all drinks on the back nine.
We'll see how chipper
you are when someone's
busy hating you!
- I'm sorry, dear, but you
can't be a kid forever.
- Oh crap, oh crap, oh crap,
oh crap, oh crap, oh crap,
oh crap! He's gonna think I blew him off.
This is the end of the world!
(hopeful music)
- [Tadano] What are your
thoughts on marriage?
- [Retsuko] I think
that I'll do it someday,
as far as I know.
- {Haida] What's this
apple-holding son-of-a-bitch
want with a girl like Retsuko?
He's gonna get bored and break her heart!
That's why I gotta punch
him right in the face!
- I think it's time...to live for me.
[dramatic music]
- [Tadano] I hope I get
to be with you forever.
(hopeful music)
- [Retsuko] Yeah.